and christian with our champion and that
closing ceremony definitely did not
start without our champion
congratulations alex uh just an
incredible finish to the tournament and
an incredible tie breaks what are your
initial feelings after this roller
coaster of the day um
i mean obviously a relief uh
everything that
i did
last six weeks
paid off in the end well
so
uh what did you do in the last six years
i started this trip uh from
now north carolina open so i went there
uh four and a half out of five and
then i
went to latvia visiting my parents for
five days
and after that i played non-stop
our world
team seniors in italy uh where
uh us took a silver behind
england
and
rolled open
nine rounds here and the playoffs
that's a lot of games and uh
now a player half or less than that of
your age would probably feel exhausted
at that point how did you feel coming
into the event was that maybe the reason
why you started off slowly
i
maybe i don't know uh no actually the
that game that uh
i was beaten by uh
lady miracopan it just
was a display of the high class i mean
he's a
much higher uh class player than
everyone else in the tournament
and
it's just like
and usually the first time player
wins this thing so he was he came really
close so
uh he will be a formidable force in a
way
uh in the years to come and uh of course
all kudos goes to laurier i mean what a
fighter what what a guy i mean
uh
just
again had a terrific playoff and i don't
know what what's why it should be me you
know who ruined his day you know uh just
for a second time
around so
yeah well well alex i have to say uh
during the tie breaks uh it just felt
like you had more energy you had more
ideas you were just bringing the
creative touch to the game did you feel
that way how did you get ready for the
this time breaks did you have any time
to get ready for the thai breaks uh no
absolutely not we just finished the game
with maxim i didn't know and go back to
my room i think we started like what 20
minutes after that
so
no i mean it's a good thing that i
didn't have any time to think it over so
just had to sit down and play
and now of course it's the lottery and
it's um well sort of library you would
expect that uh maxime and
dmitry would do really well because
there are notorious
speed players and they play in a lot of
online and
they didn't yeah just
me and larry you know people who do not
play online basically alex this is a big
title for you what does it mean to you
and how important it is that it was so
hotly contested
uh
yeah frankly uh this year i thought like
many times i thought it's not gonna be
my year i mean there was
so many people who deserve it more than
i did and uh
but
i mean it feels sweeter than you know my
first title back in 19
just because of this such a dramatic
fashion that it was
hard
i mean what can i say
i still i'm still in the playoffs
alex any
particular moments in the games that
could have gone the other way oh i don't
think so we're not going to yeah
yeah okay right now alex i know you're
still in play mode uh we just wanted to
hear your thoughts and your emotions uh
very happy for you congratulations once
again alex and you are the 2022 u.s
seniors chess champion thank you our
congratulations uh shabba go to the
world chess hall of fame across the
street pick up your 20 000
prize money you deserve it
and our congratulations sum it up for us
here we've got three champions let's
take a quick look at all of us
well let's start with the girls
final stand